today the Matt wall show James Bond is
the latest fictional character to get a
woke Rewrite by so-called sensitivity
readers this is quickly becoming a
nationwide epidemic and it really does
matter I'll explain plus MSNBC defends
Biden from the Aegis bigots who say that
you know maybe it's not a good idea to
have an elderly dementia patient as
president and participants of an
inclusivity workshop at the University
of Michigan struggle to answer the
question what is a woman it's a trick
question they say all of that and more
on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
whether you've quit your New Year's
resolutions or you're still going strong
it's never too late to start paying off
your credit cards if it's time to start
making big changes in your life there's
no better place to start than to take
control of your credit card debt you
need to check out light stream for that
a credit card consolidation for
lightstream can help you pay off your
credit cards and lock in a low fixed
interest rate rates start at 7.99 APR
with autopay and excellent credit plus
the rate is fixed so it will never
increase over the life of the loan you
get a loan from five thousand dollars to
a hundred thousand dollars without any
fees you can even get your money as soon
as you uh as the day you apply
lightstream believes that people with
good credit deserve a better loan and a
better loan experience and that's
exactly what they deliver just for my
listeners apply now to get a special
interest rate discount and save even
more the only way to get this discount
is to go to lightstream.com Walsh l i g
h t s t r e a m.com slash Walsh subject
credit approval rates range from 7.99
APR to 23.99 APR include 0.5 auto pay
discount lowest rate requires excellent
credit terms and conditions apply and
offers of change without notice visit
lightstream.com Walsh for more
information
last week we heard about an especially
loathsome group of people uh members of
a profession that shouldn't exist like
abortionists and prostitutes perhaps
ranked right in between those two on the
evil scale this is a group called
sensitivity readers and the group uh
first made it onto my radar and the
radar of lots of other people after it
was announced that one of my fellow
beloved children's authors Roald Dahl
was enduring from the grave the
humiliation of having his work
posthumously Rewritten to remove and
change quote insensitive language the
people that um doll's publisher had put
in charge of this task were called
sensitivity readers whose only job is to
read and be sensitive now not sensitive
to the author's Legacy or intentions not
sensitive to what sort of language is
most descriptive or interesting not
sensitive to the Integrity of the work
that they're butchering not sensitive to
any of that but sensitive especially and
only to the rules of wokism
as it happens after a backlash against
this PC Hatchet job of a great and
prolific writer the publisher announced
that they announced later uh last week
that the unchanged and unmolested texts
would now still be available to purchase
so they will offer the sensitive version
um and then also the insensitive
original version that now both will be
on sale you can choose it's supposed to
make everything better but it only
manages to make the whole situation even
more grotesque and gratuitous in a lot
of ways because suddenly we're treating
The Works of recently deceased modern
authors as though they're ancient
manuscripts in a foreign language
multiple versions multiple
interpretations multiple translations
are all offered you know the the Bible
has the the kgv KJV and the NIV and
dozens of other English translations
well Roald Dahl will soon have the
original the woke the Uber woke the
woker then woke
and then another version where every
single book is just a picture of a trans
guy beating a republican over the head
with a pride flag
but the scourge of these sensitivity
reader stretches far beyond rolled dump
his case is but the tip of a
purple-haired Iceberg and next uh inline
is Ian Fleming he's the creator of
course of James Bond next in line to
suffer the literary equivalent of corpse
desecration the Eric post reports this
Ian Fleming's James Bond books have been
Rewritten with modern audiences in mind
with so-called sensitivity experts
removing a number of racial references
ahead of 007's 70th Anniversary this
spring all of Fleming's Thrillers from
Casino Royale to Octopussy will be
re-released this spring after Ian
Fleming Publications the company that
owns the literary rights to Fleming's
work commissioned a review by
sensitivity readers now we should step
to the side here for a moment to quibble
uh just briefly with the way that the
post has phrased this because these
books are not being Rewritten with
modern audiences in mind I'm a member of
the modern audience and I have no
interest in Reading anything that's been
force-fed through a corporate d AI
seminar filter in fact as the backlash
against this kind of blasphemy shows
many members of the modern audience do
not want this no these books are being
Rewritten with a very narrow audience in
mind this is specifically being done to
appease the sorts of people who would
show up at a pride parade or attend a
drag brunch or you know who the sort of
people who would see a rope hanging from
a tree for a tire swing at the park and
then go to Twitter and claim that it was
a noose like those people specifically
is is is who's being uh targeted here
the particular neuroses of those sorts
of people are being catered to so don't
put this on the modern audience at large
put it on them be clear
back to the post that says the new
version of the classic novels will
include a disclaimer that reads quote
the book was written at a time when
terms and attitudes that might be
considered offensive by modern readers
were commonplace a number of updates
have been made to this Edition while
keeping as close as possible to the
original text and period in which it was
set
well no it's not as close as possible I
mean this is like if I made a delicious
batch of pancakes for breakfast and then
you took my pancakes and tossed them in
the garbage and served up some frozen
Eggos that you didn't even bother to
toast and then said well these are as
close as possible to your pancakes no
they aren't the closest thing to my
pancakes are my actual pancakes that you
threw in the trash you can't claim that
you're trying your best to preserve the
spirit of my pancakes when you had them
and you chose to discard them
maybe get a little sidetracked with this
analogy but you get my point a little
more from the post it says in some cases
racial descriptors and mentions of the
n-word have been completely scrubbed
from the text in the novel Dr No
criminals escaping from Bond are now
going to be referred to as gangsters and
the race of a doctor and immigration
officer now goes unmentioned the
ethnicity of a bar man in the in
Thunderball is also emitted as is the
race of a butler in Quantum of Solace
and many other similar additions and
omissions have been made as well but
this is not just happening to Ian
Fleming and Roald Dahl as mentioned
there is a burgeoning industry of
sensitivity readers in in publishing now
they are cancerous tumors spreading as
rapidly as di Consultants did a few
years before them their only job is to
deface the work of writers both dead and
alive
and if I were to conduct a psychological
profile of these creeps I could say with
near certainty that they are almost all
people who couldn't hack it as authors
themselves like they wanted to be
authors and they couldn't do it because
they're not good writers and so now they
spend their time bastardizing the work
of authors who are doing what they could
never do
they say that those who can't do teach
well we might also say that those who
can't write become now sensitivity
readers recently the website reason uh
called attention to this parasitic
infestation in the publishing industry
um in their report after telling the
anecdotal story of a very much still
alive writer who had his manuscript
disemboweled and dismembered by a team
of sensitivity readers hired by his
publisher in fact what we're told is
that he was uh he had written a story
and it featured prominently black
characters and the the Publishers had
assumed that he was a black author
himself and then it turns out that
although he's a racial minority they
found out well he's not actually black
and that changed everything the story
that they liked they realized this story
is now problematic because you're not
the right racial category to write it
and that's when they brought in the
sensitivity readers to change everything
to get in line with their sensitivities
uh so we're told that story then we're
told this known as sensitivity readers
or sometimes authenticity readers these
Consultants are a growing part of
publishing hire to correct
pre-publication or as we know sometimes
post-publication missteps of authors who
don't share the same traits or lived
experience to use a favored buzzword as
their characters the sensitivity readers
possible areas of expertise are as
varied as human existence itself one
representative consultancy boasts a list
of experts in the usual racial ethnical
ethnic and religious categories but also
in such areas as agoraphobia Midwestern
physical disability arms and legs
specifically that kind of disability and
gamer geek another one lists individual
readers with intersectional
qualifications depending on the content
of your novel you might hire a white
lesbian with generalized anxiety
disorder or a bisexual gender fluid
light-skinned Brown Mexican with a
self-diagnosis of autism every medical
condition every trauma every form of
Oppression sensitivity readers will
cover it all
now as always
um the thing that jumps out of you about
these woke speech police it's not their
sensitivity I mean they actually aren't
sensitive at all you have to be a
soulless psychopath to impose your own
ideological fixations onto someone
else's work whether living or dead
but rather what jumps out at you then is
there is there arrogance their unbridled
ego I mean just think about this these
people will tell an author
what would be most authentic for the
fictional characters that he created
but there's of course only one person on
Earth who can speak with final Authority
about the characters an author creates
and that is the author if I write a
story about an agoraphobic black lesbian
and I might just do that now just to
spite these people
literally whatever I have that black
lesbian say or do is authentic and
correct because she's my character it
doesn't make any sense for for you to
say well no that character doesn't say
that or do that what are you talking
about this comes from my mind these are
my characters so she's gonna do whatever
I tell her to do
she might not ring true to your
experiences but I didn't write about
your experiences
okay not everything in the world is
about you I wrote about the experiences
of this Phantom person I made up
whatever I say happened to her whatever
I say she did or said that's it that's
the final and absolute word you can't
come along after the fact and change it
on the basis that I should have written
something different first of all who are
you to say what I should have written
second even if I even if it makes sense
to say well you should have written
something different
I didn't though okay I didn't happen to
write whatever you think I should have
written I happened to write what I wrote
uh Roald Dahl Ian Fleming you can say
well they should have he he and Fleming
should have phrased it differently in
this book
uh he didn't though so that's what he
actually wrote is what you have there
you might not like it it might upset you
it makes your tummy hurt but that's what
he wrote
changing it later especially after the
author is dead is a lie it's another
attempt to bend the world
um even now the fictional world to the
egocentric whims of this insufferable
minority of cry bully vultures
now not to rehash the debates the
debates of of last week
but I need to also mention that this is
yet another reason why I choose a harsh
and Unapologetic approach uh when I'm
dealing with the woke mob and all of its
various tentacles okay
this is why this is another one of the
reasons why I approach things personally
the way that I do these are people who
have come to believe largely because
they've been told
that they have the right to have their
own particular sensitivities and
perceptions and desires and Hang-Ups and
fetishes constantly affirmed by everyone
and everything everywhere all the time
even now this right extends to books
written by authors who are dead
even that must was is uh is caught up in
this Dragnet
of narcissism
everything and everyone must affirm and
nothing must ever challenge nothing must
ever contradict they must never run into
any immovable objects they must never
encounter any wall that doesn't topple
over the moment they lightly push
against it
this is what they're told
awoke mob it's how they live it's what
they demand of the world
and I believe the only solution the only
antidote the only way out of this is to
tell them no and to say it loud and to
say it often and to say it without
apology these people need to be
contradicted they need to be rebuked
they need even to be mocked to have
their feelings dismissed to have their
sensitivities utterly disrespected and
disregarded they need this
they need it it is a need it's like the
rest of us need water and air and they
need that too but they also need this
it's their only hope of ever becoming
good productive human beings their only
hope and it is society's Only Hope of
ever escaping the grasp of these whiny
unbearable micromanaging jerks
in fact we should upset them just for
the sake of it
trolling these tyrants is a virtue it is
a virtuous act because it is an act of
rebellion against disorder Rebellion
against moral confusion and intellectual
rot
it is in other words a good and virtuous
thing
good and virtuous to say to these people
especially the sensitivity readers
kiss my ass
and also you're canceled I know that's
not the right segment for that but it
just felt right to say it so I'm
throwing it
now let's get to our five head
you know I've been doing a lot of
traveling and back on the road yet again
and uh one of the problems I generally
do okay on planes but if I'm if I'm in a
car or Uber or something like that I
tend to struggle with car sickness this
is my own disability my own marginalized
group that I'm a part of and uh that's
why I Rely so much on relief band relief
band is the number one FDA cleared
anti-nausea wristband clinically proven
to quickly and effectively prevent uh or
relieve nausea and vomiting associated
with motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more whether you need
everyday nausea relief or an occasional
cure you've got to check out relief band
like the name says relief band is just a
band you wear on your wrist to give you
relief from nausea it's as simple as
that you can even change the intensity
depending on how you're feeling relief
band has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau and over 100 000
satisfied customers they can't all be
wrong if you want the band that actually
works to relieve your nausea check out
relief band I've worked out an exclusive
offer just for our listeners if you go
to reliefband.com and use promo code
Walsh you'll get 20 off plus free
shipping and a no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee so go to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com and use promo
code walls for twenty percent off plus
free shipping
you know I got to say and uh you guys
know that I don't like to complain
um except for the 600 times a day that I
do complete what I'm not complaining I
don't like to complain except for what I
am
um regardless I was on a plane last
night and there was someone behind me
who brought their cat on board and it
was one of these very small puddle
jumper type planes
um so we were all crammed together and I
had to listen to this cat meowing and
whining
for the entire flight
and here's the thing that's all I want
to say about it people always complain
about babies crying you know babies
crying on planes especially babies cry
anywhere and people complain about it
um I will never complain about that I
I've like anyone else I've been on
planes before there's a baby crying the
whole time and I mean do I like the
sound of it do I want to hear it no but
I'm not going to complain about it after
the fact because it's a it's a baby it's
a human being
um you know they have a right to travel
like anyone else and parents have a
right to travel
um and so babies are part of human
society and so they're going to be
included in things and they should be
and and so listening to crying babies
out in public
that is an expected and and Justified
and worthwhile cost of being a member of
a human society okay
and it's also a good sign like when you
hear babies crying it means that their
babies being born and there are new
young families and this is all a
beautiful thing
but listening to your pets okay that is
a different matter entirely so I'm I am
I am different I I I approach this
differently from a lot of people which
is to say I approach it correctly
because the baby on the plane everyone
gets annoyed by that uh but I am
tolerant of it
cat meowing on the on the plane though I
think I was the only one everyone else
was like oh look at listen to the cat no
I don't want to hear that I gotta listen
to that dude because you wanted to bring
your pet on the plane you couldn't just
leave your pet and I don't know the
situation but I there just isn't a
conceivable good reason to bring a cat
on a plane it just it doesn't exist
pets are not human okay they're not
equal to us
my desire to be to not be inconvenient
is not to listen to your pet is more
important than your pet okay because I'm
a human I'm more important
I should here's where I'm at
being inconvenienced or or you know even
annoyed frustrated because uh children
and little babies are acting like
children and little babies Act
that again I'm fine with it but I
shouldn't ever I should never have to be
even slightly inconvenienced or annoyed
by your pet ever like it not even
slightly if you're putting other human
beings in a position where there are
even slightly annoyed by your pet
it you've already crossed a boundary not
saying you can't have pets but it should
never ever be my problem
I don't want to see dog crap on the
sidewalk I don't want to hear anyone's
dog barking I don't want to I just don't
want to deal with it nothing
which means don't bring your pets into
situations that were made for people
and planes are made for people
okay
good
um let's see
this is from yaf
over the weekend leading event
management platform Eventbrite once
again demonstrated its intolerance for
conservative events by taking down the
ticketing page for young Americas
Foundation Wednesday evening lecture
featuring Matt Walsh at Stanford
University
hundreds of registered attendees were
surprised to receive emails from the
company informing them that their
tickets had been canceled when a
Stanford student organizer asked an
Eventbrite customer service
representative why the tickets were
canceled she responded it does actually
violate our terms of service it does not
mean you cannot host the event however
you can no longer ticket for it via uh
Eventbrite this is far from the first
time that Eventbrite is discriminated
against events featuring Matt Walsh and
his groundbreaking documentary what is a
woman in November they did exactly the
same thing to a ticketing page for
Walsh's yaf tour stop at the University
of California Berkeley they've also
taken down page advertising Pages
advertising independent screenings of
his documentary by conservative campus
groups and a community parent
Association Okay so
I mean the the headline here is that I
have been effectively banned from
Eventbrite not just actually
scratch that I I have not been well I am
banned I would assume that if I tried to
throw my own event and put it on an
Eventbrite that they wouldn't allow me
to do it but it's like anything that
mentions me or is associated with me is
also banned because as I mentioned in
the article
the Stanford thing yeah I'm going to
Stanford and I'm going to speak and so
you're not allowed to because I guess
because I'm a I'm a scary and hateful
figure they would say then you're not
allowed to advertise it
um
but there have also been many cases of
people just trying to do a screening for
the film what is a woman or I'm not even
attending the subject is something
they're doing on their own
and Eventbrite takes down those as well
so they've effectively banned me and
anything to do with me from their
platform but they won't admit it they
won't just come out and say it so
instead they they take this piecemeal
approach and they look for any mention
of my name and then they ban that
this is one of the biggest issues with
uh with with big Tech censorship and
de-platforming is aside from the simple
fact that it's happening also the fact
that there's no transparency that
they're not honest about what they're
doing
and you want to talk about laws and
regulations we put should we put in
place
at a minimum like this is really entry
level stuff
but to begin with they should at least
be required to be honest about what
they're doing so if someone is banned
they have to say so if someone is Shadow
banned they have to say so someone's
blacklisted whatever you have to come
out and say that because that is that's
the kind of transparency that in most
other situations companies are are
required to
um
provide for their customers
but here with these big tech companies
they can do all this and not even admit
to it
meanwhile on campus the leftist students
and faculty are of course very upset
that I'm coming there on uh on Wednesday
to Stanford they've been ripping my
flyers down all the rest apparently
they've been burning some of them there
were some that were ripped down and
burned
um along with other acts of protest
there have been uh there's been
conversations on you know message boards
and all the rest of it with student
groups and they're they've been trying
to organize and and everything there was
one I saw I think yeah posted
um and it was a conversation on some
Forum about how they were going to deal
with my presence there and one of the
ideas that they were tossing around I
don't know if this is what they settled
on but it's always fun to see the
brainstorming session in action because
they'll do the brainstorming you know on
the Internet it's like thinking that
I'll never see it but of course I'll end
up seeing it
and uh in this brainstorming session the
idea they had
was that they would come to the event
and then laugh
you know throughout the event they would
laugh
and and that and that's going to be very
upsetting to me
um
which all that tells me is like I guess
just throw more jokes into my speech
and they'll be laughing at I have a
built-in laugh track now
I mean what I could do so what you're
really that's your approach then what
you're really telling me
is that
I need to come up with a speech
where I am just ruthlessly mocking
marginalized people for the entire time
so that you will be in a position now
where you're laughing at it
that's the chess move now on my part
you've you have given me no choice now
you've put me in this position
as a defense strategy
as a defense strategy I now have to come
up with the most offensive
um gratuitous
college address ever written and and
delivered
I'm not promising that right now but I
am saying that it uh
that that is that is where you're
pushing me then it's your fault and if
it does happen I want you to know it
hurts me more than hurts you
okay I don't have to do this
uh here's an article from some uh
leftists on campus in their student
newspaper
it says the right wants to erase trans
people in the last several days Trump of
the scientists have both made incendiary
claims about gender affirming care for
minors Trump himself promised that if
elected he would ban transition for all
minors Nationwide he would end Federal
support for transgender health care and
promote trans and end promoting
transition at any age criminalized
doctors and provider have provided
gender affirming care to minor children
um unfortunately one of the primary
propagandists of this looming Erasure is
coming here to Stanford to speak Matt
Walsh director of the transphobic movie
what is a woman in self-described
Theocratic fascist and transphobe of the
year uh hang on fact check I'm not a
self-described
transphobe of the year I was given that
title okay I won that title I was
awarded to me I didn't make that up so I
want a correction in the Stanford paper
um Matt Welsh perhaps the most egregious
far-right agitator in the past among
many other things Walsh has called for
execution of doctors providing
transgender Health Care attempting to
trick trans women and girls into
interviews for his movie blame drag
events for inciting the Club Q shooting
referred to youth gender affirming care
as akin to molestation and rape and
cruelly attacked trans women for living
their lives Matt Walsh wants nothing
more than to paint all supporters of
gender ideology as predators of children
well uh yeah pretty much uh yeah I mean
anyone who promotes gender ideology is
preying on children is a predator of of
children absolutely
um
because it is an inherently predatorial
ideology and it always has been from the
very beginning I mean it's an ideology
that was invented by a child abusing
pedophile John money so and it's it's it
has it has remained in that Spirit ever
since then
then it goes on and on and on and then
at the end it says um whatever it takes
Matt Walsh must not be platformed here
so whatever must happen
uh says I must not speak on campus
this is not a question of freedom of
speech but one of one of the lives of
our queer and trans students
this is always of course the
justification of uh
while they are very clearly trying to
Tamp down on suppressed sensor free
speech
they say well it's not it doesn't count
as oppressing free speech because uh
this kind of speech is going to get
people killed
and so as long as it's speech that you
can accuse as long as you can accuse the
speech of being dangerous then it's okay
to censor it
which obviously just means that you can
censor all speech because you could you
can
claim that all speech is dangerous if
you want it to be
all right moving on to this MSNBC has
some Choice words for those who would
dare suggest that Biden might be too old
for re-election here it is
there's this incredible disconnect
between the gratitude that most
Democrats have for Biden his career the
last few years and how many don't want
him to run I mean this is over 50 even
60 in some poll percent and the other
part of this the other part of this is
that you know it's it's the age question
which I know is uncomfortable to talk
about but
um you know it's a huge issue for most
Democrats
who are extreme at their best in their
80s my mom was using a chainsaw and
doing her best work in her 80s Nancy
Pelosi without chainsaw was doing a
pretty damn good job in her age
um
but with all due respect to your uh you
know to your your mother
no she was not doing she might be using
a chainsaw in her 80s it doesn't sound
not something that I would be
comfortable with if it was my mom but
no your mom was not doing her best work
in her 80s uh nobody does like I mean
maybe it depends on what we mean by best
work
but I'm trying to think of a kind of
work that someone would be best at in
their 80s
and nothing is coming to mind I'm
drawing a blank because almost any work
you can think of
um whether it's professional work or you
know artistic work or political work or
any kind of work uh physical work
mental work whatever work comes to mind
you are not going now you might still be
able to perform some of that work in
your 80s but you're not going to be at
your best with it in your 80s obviously
not
this is just absurd and this is what you
hear it's we all know that's not true so
the people that are that are trying to
uh claim that there shouldn't be any age
cap on the presidency that it's ageism
to say that hey maybe you're when you
get to your 80s you're told to be
present people that make the claims like
as always divorced from reality and
they're saying things that we all know
aren't true
based on this anecdotal oh my
grandmother she was a real firecracker
and she was uh you know she lived in 93
and she was a real firecracker
yeah I I she I'm sure she was but she
was not at her prime when she was 90
right at any sense of the term
like she
your your grandmother
whatever your grandmother is if she
lived to be elderly God bless her she's
probably a wonderful woman but she was
experiencing mental and physical decline
like a significant mental and physical
decline
and I know that I know that because it
happens to everyone because we are
humans and we are mortal and we don't
live to be 600 years old if we did then
yeah once you're in your 80s you might
still uh I mean you're
your practice your life is just
beginning
but no the average age most most people
die in their mid-80s
and it I mean if you're very very
fortunate you'll make it into your 90s
almost nobody makes it past that
so no matter what you're at the end of
your life you are at the end of your
life at this point and things are
starting to shut down that is just like
we can
plug our ears and hum to ourselves to
try to deny this reality but it just is
the reality it's not ageism to point it
out it simply is
um
and so
when we know that mental and physical
decline is is happening at a at an
increasing rate once you get into your
80s why would we
want a president to be experiencing it
when they're when they're there's there
there are lots of people who would run
for president who are not that old
doesn't mean all those younger people
are any good but Joe Biden isn't either
so we can't even say that listen yeah
he's old but he's just he's the absolute
best nobody was better and and even him
in his 80s is better than someone else
in their 50s that's not even true just
like this mediocre nothing of a person
and for some reason we say well we need
him we need it we got to stick with him
we got to stick with him until he dies
there there is no good argument for
allowing people
you know in their 80s to be present a
lot of people passed 75 to run for
president obviously there should be an
age limit on it obviously the only
argument against it is just some
nonsense platitude about ageism which no
one ever applies in the other direction
no one ever says that well if you don't
let people run until they're 35 that's
ageism
there is a much better argument for
allowing a 30 year old to be president
than there is for allowing a an 80 year
old to be president
I don't think we should do either
but it is a much you know is much better
argument on the other direction
um
and also okay
on top of the the decline
you are again at the end of your life
and so you just you don't have a
personal stake in the future nearly to
the extent that other people do because
you're not going to be around Joe Biden
when if if he uh hopefully is voted out
of office in this next election cycle or
God forbid he's re-elected
um either way
no he's he's not gonna be around for
very long after if he doesn't die in
office when he gets out of office he'll
be around probably for a couple years
and then he'll die
um because that's what happens because
again he's in his 80s
so isn't that also concerning
to have someone who
they're on their way out they're not
even going to be here they're not gonna
whatever decisions they make they're not
even going to be here to experience the
consequences of it
are we comfortable with that
no I'm not
all right
I wanted to
let's see I want to mention this also
this this is a story so I I
would read some of the story and you're
going to think that I'm going a certain
direction with it yeah but but I'm not I
will surprise you slightly
uh Daily Mail police have pictured a
Texas man arrested after his crazed pit
bulls mauled an elderly man to death and
badly injured the victim's wife
Christian Alexander Moreno 31 was
charged with attack by dangerous dog
causing death and injury to an elderly
person both felonies according to a
press release by the San Antonio Police
Department
he was pictured being perp walked from
his home after Friday's horrific mulling
which was captured on video the victim
has been named as 81 year old uh Ramon
najeras attack heard along the 2800
block of depla Street on the city's west
side where Harris and his wife 74 were
visiting friends when they got out of
their car the couple were set upon by uh
by the two American Staffordshire
Terriers who had escaped their yard so
this I guess that would be this is a
bully breed of dog
uh it's a bully breed but not a pit bull
right I think
um neither victim has been named with
the surviving woman said to be receiving
critical care now
the San Antonio fire department they
arrived on the scene
and there's video there's so there's
there's video of the actual attack of
this elderly man being
I mean I hate to put it this way but
being eaten by these dogs and the video
is I I happen to see this video very
much not wanting to see it but it's one
of those things scrolling on social
media and boom it pops up and there it
is
um
so there's video of the attack and then
the video continues and we see the
police the fire department show up and
they're kind of like fending off the dog
they have their their pickaxes and
they're fending off the dogs this goes
on for a while and the police show up
and then some animal uh you know uh the
the people that deal with animals
Animal Care Services came and they took
the dogs and then brought them somewhere
else and then they were we were told we
were assured humanely euthanized
that's already a sad statement about
society when nobody including the cops
would no one shows up and just shoots
these damn things
and even when the Animal Care Services
come oh we got to make sure we humanely
euthanize
they just mauled an elderly man to death
he is dead on the sidewalk in the middle
of an American town uh like this is some
kind of third world country this is not
okay we are not a third world country
and so we should not have animal
mullings should not be a thing that you
have to worry about in a modern American
town
but you do
because people bring these dogs into the
into the neighborhood nobody shoots the
dogs even though they they make sure
like well we're gonna take the dogs and
then and then and then they were
euthanized
shot the police said just shoot them
shoot them right there on the spot
and no one comes out of the house with a
gun and just shoots the animals
um
but that's my point
so you know how I feel about pit bulls
and any any of the bully breeds of dogs
uh I think they should all be banned and
they shouldn't be allowed in
neighborhoods to me that's incredibly
obvious
so I'm not going to harp on that because
you know how I feel about it
when I was
the thing that I kind of focused on when
I saw the video is that there's a video
of it and I know that we're used to this
by now it's barely even we just take it
for granted anytime anything horrible
happens we see it on video and so we all
then also witness it
but this modeling I mean it goes on for
a while and this elderly man it's I I
cannot think of a worse way to die
and and he is mulled to death by these
dogs and obviously not going to play the
video
and uh
and there's apparently someone in it
they look like they're in a car and
they're just filming it the entire they
said they're filming it for like minutes
while this man is killed
nobody you can hear some people shouting
at the dogs no one attempts to intervene
nobody this is a neighborhood there are
people all around they're in the houses
no one does anything
to help this man instead they film it
now you can make an argument for filming
maybe you can make an argument for
filming uh horrific events when it's a
when a person is committing a crime and
then you could argue well I want to film
it so that we could capture this person
after the fact that it all we have the
evidence okay
but even in that case your first
priority and your first responsibility
as a human being is to help someone if
you can uh not to think about well uh
you know after this person is murdered
then we'll have video of it at least
but at least yeah the video comes in
handy there in this case what what do
you need the video for at all why does
this video need to exist I I mean I'm
not being glib about it but it's you
know there's not going to be any
question about what happened to this man
uh we don't need to check the video to
see that he was Malta death by dogs it's
incredibly obvious to everyone so you
don't need that what do you need the
video for why does this have to be on
video and then why does it have to be on
social media
I I just can't imagine you you're what
you see an elderly man being mulled to
death and your reaction is to pull out
of to get it on video for what
um
now we could talk about the laws against
pit bulls which I of which I think there
should be
but we need to start
passing laws and enforcing laws that are
already in the books uh to hold people
accountable when they are bystanders and
make no attempt
you know a bystander is just sitting
there filming while someone is being
beaten murdered like we need to start
holding people accountable for that
this this is not
it's just it's not it's uh it's ugly
it's sub-human behavior is what we're
all becoming we're so I think we're so
desensitized to everything because we
see all this stuff on social media and
it's like the when you when you
encounter in real life you immediately
pull your phone out and then start
experiencing this real thing through
your phone as if you're kind of removed
from it but you're not you're right
there you're a person that's a person
they need your help help them
now
I know we can only go so far in blaming
people for not acting heroically there's
a reason why we call it heroism is that
it's it's above and beyond what you
would normally expect and so if we start
expecting everyone to be heroes then
we're not really and it's not heroism
anymore if it's expected
um
and so I understand so there's a certain
line there you know nobody knows what
they would do in a certain situation
like are you going to put yourself In
Harm's Way to help a stranger hopefully
you would but that does require heroism
maybe you start you know then you start
thinking about your own family and your
kids you want to make it back to them
and I understand you think about all
those things but
um
so maybe we don't expect bystanders to
be superheroes but we do have to expect
them to be human beings
and I just find it hard to believe
nobody could do anything to try to help
like just throw get I don't know get
some bricks get rocks like throw stuff
at this the dogs do something get a baby
noise a baseball bat no one has anything
no net no one has a gun
maybe not but I mean this is Texas no
one has a gun really
no one has a crowbar no one has anything
all right finally here's something else
from yaf they uh they tweeted during the
University of Michigan inclusive
leadership Workshop Dr rushing Dr
rushing struggles with responding to
Matt Walsh's what is a woman question
um so this is some sort of that's some
sort of workshop at a university
University of Michigan and they're
trying to deal with this question and I
always enjoy these videos when we find
them so here it is
if you're looking at the comment that
they shared was
um I was just sharing in my group how
one of my co-workers challenged my
identity using the trick question of
what is a woman
we inform and they unfortunately did not
have a chance to you know deal with
their group so I don't know if anyone
has a way to respond to like shut that
down in the moment
um like what how can we be the bystander
in that moment um how can we interrupt
the harm in action
um
foreign
asking someone like well what is a woman
which is just
gender is already a social construct so
they even ask that question just shows
that this person doesn't understand the
idea of like what gender is
um so many so many things that we
consider as truth
it's just how
that's just what the systems tell us
right
um now that I've had a chance to come
download with it
um
my first instinct would be if you have
the energy and again sometimes the best
thing to do is be like I'm not engaging
with you they just walk away Rose I am
so sorry you have to deal with that
um
okay I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go off
right now
that's good it never gets old it never
gets old for me anyway it really never
gets old
um and they uh it's a trick question
right what is a woman what do you do
with this trick question it is I cannot
think of a question
that is less of a trick question than
what is a woman or really anytime
anytime you use a word and someone says
what does that word mean
that is
there's no trick it is we want to know
what you mean by the words that you're
using what are you trying to communicate
you might not be able to answer it let's
make it a trick question
um
but you notice it
even when they're talking amongst
themselves
uh they still they still struggle with
this question
because they can answer it for all the
reasons that we've covered extensively
um
but you see how
you see why they're so afraid to face
someone who is not in their club with a
question like this
because amongst themselves at least well
they're all in the same side they're all
in the same tribe
and no one is they all have the same
agenda no one's actually interested in
the truth they all understand that the
idea is to avoid objective reality
objective truth
and they'll also take you know if when
they're talking about each other
they'll give each other the out
and so there there are just like talking
points or little slogans they'll throw
out something like
somebody brings up what is a woman
they talk around it for a bit well you
know it's a trick question gender is a
social construct and they throw out that
that slogan and then the other people
will say that are in the tribe oh yeah
sure okay
but if they're talking to someone's not
in the tribe uh well we're not going to
give you that out
it's not going to be that easy you can't
just throw out a slogan and and have us
say oh well all right
because then you throw out the slogan
we're going to want to know you what you
mean by that slogan
oh gender is a social construct so it's
a what is so it's an invalid question
because what because the word woman
doesn't mean anything you're saying it's
just a it's a constructed thing doesn't
mean anything
well so why is anyone identifying as it
and why why should I respect it at all
and still doesn't answer the question of
like what that person means when they
say it
so keep trying folks you're not there
yet you'll get there well you'll never
get there but keep trying because it's
funny
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
the our president is for sale sale over
at dailywire.com shop Ends Tonight this
is your
I'm pretty sure we said that yesterday
but this is really your last chance to
take advantage of up to 40 off select
daily wire merchandise but far more
importantly items from my swag Shack
that's right this is your last chance to
get the John The Walrus book and plushie
bundle at its lowest price ever we've
been telling you it's your last chance
for literally weeks as I've been reading
these ads and this time it really is
your last chance the sale ends tonight
so don't wait to get your hands on the
greatest LGBT children's book of all
time in addition to your very own walrus
proudly displaying his he him wall rocks
pronouns it's cuddly it's controversial
and it's a deal that won't last
go to dailywire.com shop today before
time Runs Out
Fisher gaming says the fastest
cancellation was of Alex Jones he was
right about everything too even the
Liars who are now suing him for his cat
uh yes literally they want his cat in
addition to the trillion with the T
dollars they want from him because he
said a mean thing uh really I I hadn't
thought I'm out of the loop on that one
they want they're trying to sue him to
take his cat away from him
um
I mean if I was doing someone the last
thing I would want is there is there cat
that's for sure but yeah well I think
Alex Jones I mean obviously an example
of someone who's been canceled the
platform like from almost every platform
um the fastest
I don't know because this was a this is
a campaign that was ongoing uh against
Alex Jones for many years
and then it kind of kicked into high
gear
seemingly all of a sudden but it wasn't
really all of a sudden this was an
ongoing campaign
the thing that separates the Scott Adams
thing is that um
he was yeah I I guess on the left they
had long considered him to be you know
far right or something because he had
shared opinions that were deemed
conservative uh although I don't even
think he really is concerned I don't
think he would call himself that
um but even in spite of that he was kind
of just doing his thing and then all at
once he's everything is taken you know
within like 24 hours
um
and this but this is also how the
cancellations work now I mean they're
always you can't really measure which
one's the fastest this is this is just
how it goes once the once the uh the the
snowball starts rolling down the hill
you've got an avalanche
uh
Ari says Matt I hope you read this
comment I need to tell you I actually
jumped for Joy when you announced the
return of the flannels I hugged my
family started crying tears of happiness
had already replaced ever shared my
wardrobe with plaid shirts I'll always
be rocking polka dot or flannel shirts
in your honor thank you for saving my
life
you know so many responses just like
that people are
um
I think I think I think everyone feels
that I think everyone feels even people
don't watch the show
uh they still feel that something has
been set right there's a balance that's
been restored to the universe and it's
uh it's an almost Indescribable
unquantifiable thing but we all right we
can all sense it
um
tie my shoe says now that now that
Matt's crew relented we should demand
suit Friday
the legs of Rook says now that flannel
Friday is gone it could be replaced with
formal Friday well at least got the
alliteration where Matt wears the suit
again
uh no no we're not we're done we're done
with that we're not playing we're not
playing games with the Wardrobe anymore
or with your hearts as the audience
the quote uh
who's up actually boys are in sync
um
friendly neighborhood Snyder man says
Matt needs to replace the bleep noise
with a cuckoo clock sound effect
I don't know about that let's try that
out I'll give a writer something to do
uh okay you
'll see what that sounds like
Steve says yes Governor DeSantis has
great ideas and can well communicate
them and he'll make a great vice
president under President Trump look
let's
I don't know what's going to happen in
2024 that's not going to happen and I
know that there are some people that
they like Trump and I like to santis and
they're trying to figure out a way to to
make it all work and so this is the idea
that I hear mentioned all the time that
well the status will be on Trump's
ticket
never gonna happen just simply not going
to happen
um Trump would never want that because
he's not going to want someone on the
ticket who who he would worry might over
you know overshadow him he also does he
does Trump doesn't want to feel like
people are voting for the ticket at
least some people because they want the
guy at the bottom of the ticket rather
than him so Trump will never want that
and I don't think it stands for one
either it's maybe a really bad move on
to scientist's part
um
for a lot of reasons
and one is that just in general you
become vice president you are you are
hitching yourself to a wagon that you're
not in control over and uh and that you
know you're the rest of your political
career is going to going to depend on
that even though you really don't have
any power you don't do anything as vice
president this doesn't seem like the
smartest uh political move
and then also politics is all about
timing so I don't I still don't I don't
know who's going to be
who's going to get the nomination it
might be neither of those guys that's
possible
maybe somebody else will come along
we're not thinking about
but I don't know who it's going to be
I do know though that politics is all
about timing and this is Rhonda
Sanchez's time doesn't mean he's going
to win
the primary or the general election but
if he is going to win it this is the
time when he's going to win the time is
now 2028 is a million years away it
might as well be a million years
right now he's at front he's at the lead
he's in the conversation he's driving
the conversation all these things uh
2028 he'll have by then he'll have been
out of the governor's uh Mansion for a
couple of years and and
who knows what certainly it will not be
like it is now and you got to take
advantage of the timing when it comes
standing at six foot four inches Abraham
Lincoln was our tallest president
already towering over the men of his era
a young girl once asked Lincoln why he
always wore such a tall stovepop top uh
uh uh hat that made him look even taller
honestly looked down at her removed his
hat showing her inside of the hat and
said to better store all of my great
Jeremy's razors that is a 100 True
historical fact was an important moment
in history the left wants you to forget
and probably why they keep devaluing all
our currency with Lincoln's face on it
but while the left cancels history
Jeremy's razors celebrates that history
that's why we're still offering 30 off
any razor during our President's Day
sale but act fast because the sale ends
tonight you can get the Glorious smooth
six uh razor for a close comfortable
shave that cuts hair below the surface
which is especially useful for uh
prolonging that Lincoln inspired
mustache mustacheless beard look at that
you're going with however you shave just
don't let the radical left turn our
founding fathers into our founding
non-birthing parents go to
jeremy'sraisers.com for your last chance
to get a 30 off woke free shave kit now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today the media is running with a poll
which is supposed to show that uh women
are oppressed in the workplace but
instead it manages to prove something
else CNBC reports there's a major
confidence gap between men and women in
the workplace though it might not be in
the way that you'd expect a majority 64
of women think they can do their
manager's job better than them versus 47
of men who believe the same according to
a monster survey of 6847 workers
conducted a Fri on February that
perspective doesn't necessarily reflect
that women feel proficient in their jobs
but rather they feel undervalued and
overlooked for management roles
according to monster career expert Vicky
salimi salami uh tells us CNBC quote
women feel they can do their manager's
job she says but the frustration is why
aren't they given the opportunity to do
it
um why aren't you given the opportunity
to do your manager's job well because
your manager is doing it that might be
the reason
do you think your manager should just be
fired on the spot so they can try you
out for the role and even if they do
even if they fire your manager and
replace him with a woman
why should you why should you
specifically be the woman who takes his
place
would you be satisfied if another woman
was promoted and not you
it's actually it's a statistical
certainty that many of the women who
said they could do their manager's job
better many of them have managers who
are women so if a woman is promoted over
a woman that's an example of sexism
against women how does this work exactly
see this is one of the many fundamental
problems with the claims of sexism and
oppression against women in the
workplace
the women who are inclined to make these
kinds of complaints will still make them
even if their management team is already
dominated by women as it is in many
companies
have you ever known a feminist to say
well I didn't get this opportunity but
another woman did and so I'm happy this
is a win for The Sisterhood
they might claim to have that attitude
but none of us have ever encountered it
in real life
I certainly haven't
so often when a member of an allegedly
marginalized group complains about
discrimination
they're really complaining about how
they personally have been treated or how
they perceive themselves to have been
treated
it is a selfish complaint disguised as
concerned for the group
but then you quickly discover that this
person will take no comfort in finding
out that other people in the group
aren't having those experiences so when
they say don't treat us this way what
they really mean is don't treat me this
way
and that might seem like an obvious
thing to point out but it's it is it's
it's an important distinction because
it's a very different sort of complaint
whether it's true or not that they're
being mistreated you know and often it's
not true but whether it's true or not
still it's worth noting the nature of
the complaint which is usually personal
and self-centered
bringing it back to women in the
workplace the fact is that women are
being promoted women are getting
opportunities and if anything in big
corporations at least they're getting
more opportunities than men these
companies are actively looking to staff
their management teams with anyone other
than white males they have a vested
interest in doing that
but the women who still complain about a
sexist conspiracy to Rob them of
opportunities they aren't likely to take
any solace in the fact that other women
are in fact getting promoted that's
because again the women who say you're
being unfair to women
who says that is often really saying
you're being unfair to me
doesn't really care about women in
general she cares about herself which is
fine y'all look out for number one but
at least be honest about it this is
perfectly evidenced by the career expert
Vicki in the CNBC article saying that
women aren't getting the chance to do
their managers jobs
regardless of the fact that many of
these women have managers who are women
it turns out that uh you know the women
making the complaint don't want a woman
to be manager they want themselves
personally to be manager
which again is different
back to the article women are far less
likely to say that they feel they get
the same quantity and quality of
opportunities as men in the workplace 66
percent of men believe everyone at work
gets the same access to Opportunities
versus just 23 percent of women
according to monster the opportunities
Gap has a compounding effect among women
at levels at all levels in the workplace
women say that having a Clear Vision for
the future of their career is a top
priority for them and a lack of
potential advancement is the biggest red
flag that would lead them to turn down a
job offer
so the poll finds that a majority of
women
complain that the company they work for
is unfair and biased while also claiming
that they can do jobs that they have not
been judged qualified for
if you were trying to come up with a
poll to convince employers to hire men
instead of women I don't think you could
you could have done a better job than
this
though some of this polls supposed to
motivate Employers in the opposite
direction like you know hey women are
likely to have an inflated sense of
importance and also complain a lot now
hire more of them
that seems to be the sales pitch and
it's not my sales pitch by the way I'm
not saying that I'm telling you that's
what the survey apparently says
now to what extent it actually reflects
the the opinion of the majority of women
I don't know
those are the services
article ends this way some 77 percent of
men believe everyone is paid the same
presumably they mean paid the same for
the same work versus 24 of women
concerning concerning given that women
say fair and equal wages is the number
one most important benefit to them in
the workplace the gender wage gap which
has persisted for decades now sits at
the average woman being paid 82 cents
for every dollar paid to a man according
to the Census Bureau the gap widens for
many women of color
now of course we couldn't conclude this
without the trusty old wage Gap myth if
you're curious the the article supports
the women get paid 82 cents for every
dollar that a man earns Claim by linking
to a fact sheet on the census.gov
website which tells us that the median
earnings of men are about fifty seven
thousand dollars a year this is back in
2019. while the median for women is
around 47 000.
these are the numbers
that you get if you take all of the men
in every profession and throw them into
one pot all of the women in every
profession throw them into another and
then compare the two
but that comparison is totally
meaningless as it obviously doesn't take
into account things like hours worked
overtime experience skill effort
qualifications career choice Etc
it doesn't even bother to compare men
and women in the same industry let alone
the same positions within those
Industries
instead it effectively Compares you know
male commercial airline pilots to female
hairdresser dressers and male surgeons
to a female daycare workers and so on it
makes an even one-to-one comparison
among all these groups
it is in fact a perfect example of how
you lie with Statistics because the
figure they end up with 82 cents on the
dollar
is technically true if you don't control
for any meaningful factors whatsoever
but they never mentioned that detail
when they cite the figure
which makes it effectively a lie
so
what is the real takeaway here
what can we learn from the fact that
according to the survey a majority of
women in the workforce feel that they're
being oppressed and being treated
unfairly because of their sex
well we learned just that that it's a
Feeling this is what the oppression
narrative is ultimately grounded in it's
something that people feel something
that they are indeed encouraged to feel
these are feelings instilled and
fostered in them
the poll says that a majority of women
believe they feel that they aren't
getting equal opportunities
very much in the same way that uh so
many people believe feel you know the
wage Gap
we aren't supposed to ever ask is
whether these beliefs and feelings
actually reflect reality
that's because we do investigate that
question we will find out very often and
very quickly that they just simply don't
and that's why not all women in the
workforce but at least the majority who
took this poll
are today canceled
no do it for uh the show today I'll talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
LA's radical district attorney suspends
a prosecutor for misgendering a trans
identifying child rapist Media Matters
attacks me me whom everybody loves so
for advocating a total ban on
transgenderism and the U.S treasury
secretary takes a trip to Ukraine check
it out on the Michael Knowles show
[Music]